welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
boss in the Mandalorian season 3 just
released a new trailer ahead of the
season premiere on March 1st and Brace
yourselves for more order 66 trauma but
you know hey lightsabers multicolored
armor sets the Star Wars loved by fans
who like to wait in line to buy toys to
Galaxy's Edge is back
I'm gonna break down this trailer brain
by frame for all the details that you
might have missed and catch you up on
where we last saw these characters from
the Mandalorian season 2 and the Book of
Boba Fett because let's be honest those
two episodes spoke about that were
really Mandalorian season 2.5 not that
we complained also a reminder to
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive that's gonna launch February 17th
in which every week I will be digging
even deeper into stuff like everything
everywhere all at once with a more
pointed Focus while I continue to break
down Easter eggs here on new rock stars
let's get started with this trailer
our people are scattered
like stars in the galaxy
what are we
what do we stand for we opened with
composer Olympic urinson's piercing
flutes in the universe Mandalorian flute
is the best event but for the Show's
music gorenson uses a recorder a better
recorder than the graph that we used to
play in elementary school
a group of seven Mandalorian armored
figures hiking across a rocky desert
train that looks a lot like Arizona or
Utah or the volume's impression of them
actually if you look closely through the
haze leading them appears to be bo Katan
with din jar into the left of her but
there are even more Mandos in This
Magnificent Seven ones with a variety of
colorful mismatched armor there's a shot
of four of them dumping their armor and
Unison followed by a shot of red and
white armored one with a rifle and jet
pack turning back toward a red and
teal-plated Mandalorian with an
interesting Signet on his shoulder maybe
a wolf like the loath wolf and behind
him a Tana green helmeted thick boy and
then a fourth blue helmeted one in the
background on the right and then this
shot we saw the d23 trailer of ninjarian
stepping past three more there are two
white helmeted ones and another orange
helmeted one the white helmets could be
part of the night owls who do have
thinner more angled helmets with the
visors and more of that avian y shaped
than the classic Mandalorian t-shape all
in all we are just seeing a lot more
than seven mandalorians across all these
shots so this group of seven in the
distance may be bogoton leading denjarin
and her other remaining Night Owl group
including Costco Reeves and ax woes whom
we met alongside bocaton in season 2 on
the planet Trask and then some others
like the white helmeted ones all on a
hike to meet up with a bigger group of
mandalorians from various other clans
who have been scattered across the
Galaxy like stars now remember in book
of overhead episode 5 the armorer shared
her perspective of the history of Boca
time I provoked on wield of the dark
saber at the end of rebels when she
hoped to reunite the scattered
Mandalorian Clans under her Rule and
retake the planet of Mandalore but
failed because according to the armor
the darksaber was not won by combat and
that brought a curse upon bogutan's
house Bo Katan Kris was born of a mighty
house but they lost sight of the way her
rule ended in tragedy they lost their
way and we lost our world had our sect
not been cloisted on the moon of
Concordia
we would have not Survived the Great
Purge so I think what's really going on
here is that DIN jarin and bogoton have
called a congress of representatives
from all surviving Mandalorian Clans
Gathering them on Concordia Concordia
does have a Terrain that looks kind of
like this their goal is to try to
organize all the mandalorians into some
unified body and then maybe to
democratically select a new leader
create a new system of government but
you know since these are mandalorians I
assume it'll just devolve into partisan
bickering because mandalorians like to
solve their problems by fighting now
back in the book of Boba Fett didn't jar
and told the armor that he would next go
to Mandalore to be forgiven for his
transgressions remember that
transgression was removing his helmet
his clan never ever ever does that and
she said that he would have to go to The
Living Waters beneath the mines
Mandalore also a reminder that things
did end Frosty between dinjar and
bokotan after din won that dark saber in
combat for mop Gideon and the
Mandalorian season 2 finale which really
complicated bogoton's goal to redeem her
humiliation among all the other
mandalorians and now it kind of sounds
like din jarin is stepping up as that
presumed leader he says our people are
scattered are like stars in the galaxy
what are we what do we stand for it
sounds like our man is speechifying he's
appealing to all these scattered
mandalorians to ReDiscover a common
culture in Creed you know as much as I
love the mystery of grogu on this show
the show is called the Mandalorian and
that to me is the strongest thematic
undercurrent of the series let's move on
to the next section
[Music]
you're not just learning about how to
fight
a fight you also have to know how to
navigate the Galaxy
so dingar and Pilots is in one nebu
Starfighter remember he got that from
Pele Moto in the book of Boba Fett they
remodeled its silver the original
Astromech Port replaced with this bubble
Dome jumpsuit for grogu to ride in now
in another shot grugu actually moves
back to din's lap I guess the back seat
too far away from Papa it actually looks
like here that din is sleeping as an
Astromech pilots from the back from a
new Port that is located behind grogu's
jump seat now this fighter is flying at
freaking hyperspeed which is pretty
crazy because the kiniso switch that
Moto installed previously only allowed
him to accelerate to really high speeds
that looks like hyperspeed but really
with not hyper speed fully it's just not
common for fighters of this size to have
room for hyperdrives but you know with
Luton rails bondor Hall craft and Andor
just seems to be something Star Wars is
doing more often now denjar tells grogu
that to be a Mandalorian means learning
how to navigate the Galaxy which is
pretty sad because it means that didn't
yarn a definitive aspect of Mandalorian
lifestyle is to be a Wanderer on to the
next clip that way
you'll never be lost
okay the N1 Starfighter lands back on
Navarro and Navarro has dramatically
developed both in terms of cleaning up
the structure following Imperial
occupation but with new more vertical
structures building up there's yellow
flags flapping in the breeze so Navarro
is less of a town of bounty hunters
getting drunk and now a place with more
of a cultural identity the gate that
they land by is no longer crumbling and
we see a good old kawakian monkey lizard
and now the kawaki monkey lizards just
hang out in the trees remember in season
one they roasted these four things on
spits now this little guy must be a mix
of VFX because it totally maintains its
license B crumb practical look but it's
like removed from any place some puppet
hand could be they'd probably Marion
edit it with sticks and then they
painted out those marionette sticks and
post-production and notice how grogu has
a much sleeker new bassinet it comes
with a headlight and it looks more
heavily armored and behind him in the
distance ball is a very confused looking
r5d4 that's the red plated Astromech
droid originally from a new hope that's
the one with a bad motivator he showed
back up in pelimoto's shop and now
serves as dangerous Astromech and why I
wouldn't trust this busted dumbass to be
my DD hey greed karga is now the
magistrate of Navarro it seems to have
Steve Harvey's wardrobe budget he and
dingar and shake hands at the foot of
the ig-11 statue that stands in the Town
Square ever since he sacrificed himself
to save them season one notice how that
statue props his foot on what is that
yup that is the helmet of a stormtrooper
Dan and grogu pilot threw a rainy
atmosphere perhaps making their descent
to the ruins of Mandalore or wherever
poketan is because later we see Mando in
the throne room where bocaton sits in
the previous trailer and his helmet is
covered in raindrops there it's also
possible that they're approaching the
Rainy Camino planet to investigate
persian's cloning operation not really
sure it rains on lots of planets not
just on Camino but hey you know what
time it is Bam it's geology time geology
is the 16 time award-winning
personalized skin care company
recognized in hypebeast's birdie Men's
Health Esquire and ask men grooming
Awards with over 6 000 5 Star reviews
and now they offer products for whatever
you need just take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz and geology figures out
your routine for you geology creates
simple and effective skin care and Hair
Care routines customized just for you
with ingredients that are proven to work
no matter what you're trying to take
care of for Hair Care youth geology's
co-wash it's a specially formulated
cream cleanser that removes buildup and
cleanses hair without the harsh
ingredients of typical shampoo geology
also has body washes that are free of
harsh ingredients smell great and are
refillable for skin care geology can
protect your skin from environmental
stress with vitamin C plus e for Relic
serum to keep your skin looking young
and healthy and then a bit of
dermatologist tested aluminum free
deodorant right now for limited time
geology is hooking our viewers up with
an absolutely insane offer if you use
the code rockstar70 they will give you
an additional 70 off their award-winning
skincare trial set we did the math and
that's five products for just 15 on top
of that you can take an additional 30
bonus offer on one of their brand new
skin hair and body products of your
choice when you add that to your trial
to get started just click the link in
the description on to the next section
I'm going to Mandalore
so that I may be forgiven for my
transgressions
away
okay we see close-up of the best car
Ladle dipping into water as we once
again see this clip from the book above
a vet when denjaron tells his intentions
to the armor then we see from overhead
the ruins of this Mandalorian City
perhaps this is tsundari that is the
Dome City that seemed to be the one that
got bombed in the armor or story in the
book of boba fed but notice the fields
of green to the left of the ruins these
are likely fed by The Living Waters of
Mandalore and are proof that these
Springs still flow now we got a lot of
folks asking if this Astromech is
chopper from Rebels no this is r5d4 who
again for some reason Mando is allowing
to Astromech pilot is in one Chopper
will appear in Ahsoka so you're gonna
have to wait until then hang out with
that little war criminal I honestly
don't know why you all love him so much
it's this crappy little turd he should
burn in Droid hell the N1 Pilots through
celebratory fireworks maybe Tatooine is
celebrating light day or the anniversary
of the second death star Destruction
battle of Endor and in giant let's grow
goop flip the canizo switch how nice of
them moving on if something dangerous
happening out there and by the time it
becomes big enough for you to act
it'll be too late
we got a few gloves Shadows here first
off we are back on Coruscant this is the
first time we've seen it in live action
in this era of Star Wars I guess since
George Lucas added it to the victory
Montage of the Return of the Jedi
special edition and our old friend Dr
Pershing is visiting remember he was the
one trying to get grogu's genetic
material in season one on behalf of moth
Gideon and based on the Camino and
looking patch that he was wearing at
that time the Assumption has always been
that it could be part of some Palpatine
cloning plot Captain Carson Teva returns
with a new patch of his own it looks a
bit like a Rancor if you ask me he
warned to something dangerous happening
out there perhaps the rise of the first
order we enter a cave with light pouring
in from above and a blue glow in the
distance maybe the minds of Mandalore
leading to The Living Waters and Mando
pulls an old helmet out of the dirt Orly
out of the ash this could be one of the
victims of tsundari's bombing when those
droids are roaming through the ash we
did see some Mandalorian helmets buried
in the foreground and then perhaps the
most striking shot of the trailer a
scene from the Jedi Temple as four Jedi
with their lightsabers drawn embracing
for someone with another lightsaber
cutting through a door now I checked
these four Jedi are not any Jedi that we
know none of these four are centrally we
saw security footage of Anakin killing
him somewhere else but yes this does
look like this season will return again
tragically to the night of Order 66
making this the likeliest person to be
cutting through the door probably best
that we are seeing this from grogu's
point of view just like in that
flashback of the book of Boba Fett so if
Anakin slash Vader accessed a chamber
where grogu was none of them would have
made it out alive including grogu I just
highly doubt that Anakin ever knew grogu
existed it would just open up too many
plot holes so rather I think this scene
is going to make us think that it's
Vader but when those doors open it will
be grogu's long mysterious rescuer many
a fan theory has been hoping it is Mace
Windu boom fans hope survived that fall
from Palpatine's quarters but I think
the likelier option based on him getting
mentioned in Obi-Wan Kenobi last year is
Quinlan boss Quinlan not only survived
Order 66 he joined the path of Jedi
refugees that Obi-Wan met up with and
Quinlan boss continued to Aid this group
just sounds like the kind of thing that
grogu could have benefited from and
please please can it be a boss who saved
grogu but I also like the theory that
this Jedi Temple shot might not be from
Order 66 at all and instead could be an
even further flashback to the older era
when Jedi mandalorians were at War and
the darksaber was stolen from the Jedi
Temple stolen or reclaimed depending on
his certain point of view I like the
idea and I hope we see that tarvisla
history at some point I just don't know
about that these Jedi robes look period
specific to the time of Order 66 and
back in the older older days Jedi wore
different kinds of clothing on to the
next clip
[Applause]
hang on kid
[Applause]
yeah okay it looks like then Jordan's
gonna get mixed up in that chase he's
actually piloting a Mandalorian Gauntlet
Starfighter and he's fleeing a group of
Thai interceptors now remember these
Gauntlet Fighters were piloted by the
Death Watch during the Clone Wars and
then we visit this Droid bar that has a
mix of Astromech droids and holy crap
separatists B1 battle droids what the
hell are these things still doing around
at this point in history I mean I don't
care I love it but it looks like this
bar is Droid exclusive like maybe it's
of alcohol they just kind of plug in and
recharge maybe they power down just
enough to take the edge off make them
forget how much they hate their kids
then we see this group of blue armor
Death Watch mandalorians plunging from a
drop ship I love this shot we saw in the
celebration footage we saw in the t23
trailer and now it looks like they are
attacking Navarro or engaging in some
kind of conflict that is set Navarro
because that mound the left of pause
Vizsla is the same base of the ig-11
statue with the Stormtrooper heads it
looks like the ig-11 part of the statue
has been destroyed he's now only two
pieces of rebar poke up so what the hell
did you do pause but yeah it looked
looks like we're gonna see some War
break out between the two factions the
Mandalorian one faction being the Death
Watch Children of the watch and another
faction being headed by Boca tan and
dinjaran the night owls and whatever
other allies from the scattered Clans
the mandalorians are able to recruit and
part of this fight we see a Mandalorian
trip in a Necto to the Delight of these
on zealans this is the same race as Babu
Frick the best thing to come out of the
rise of Skywalker on to the last clip
this is the way
[Music]
all right
okay so our boy grogu has been
weaponizing the force and in this case
he's using a force push on some kind of
wookie-like species I thought maybe this
might be a towels from Ordo plutona and
Clone Wars but those things have a more
pear-shaped form very differently shaped
eyes I don't know this would just be a
pretty serious anatomic Readjustment of
what we saw in Clone Wars also this
planet doesn't look cold enough for a
towels really this just looks something
from ruffle Corey's concept art whatever
this fella is he carries a jade colored
blade or a kind of ax that falls out of
his hand when grugu tosses it backward
overall folks this season looks really
really good I think it's gonna be a
season that lives up to the
mandalorian's name and premise an arc
that explores Mandalorian culture and
history on a level that we haven't
really seen yet and I cannot wait to
break down every episode starting March
1st right here on new rock stars but the
reminders should also subscribe to new
Rockstar's new channel the Deep dive
launched in February 17th with deeper
investigations from me every week you
can follow it on all socials at Deep
dive NR you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at EA boss follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new Rockstar
server breakdowns and theories of
everything you love thanks for watching
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]